all right welcome back to part three of
this special series of awesome bills we
look back at the props and costumes we
made for the Mad Max fury road review so
in this week's episode we're going to be
looking at the furiosa or Becky the
curiosa costume that we built for Tamra
more specifically the mechanical arm
because most of the other elements were
just things that I had the belt and some
of the leather straps and stuff like
that but the mechanical arm was
something that I had to kind of fashion
together using parts that I had lying
around the shop so let's take a look all
right so today we're gonna be building
furiosa's arm the mechanical arm I'm
just gonna have to use kind of whatever
materials they have lying around the
shop I don't have a lot of time to go
who have stuff so that's what I'm gonna
do I'm just gonna rummage through some
of my bits pieces of plastic I've got
tons of foam and little bits of you know
plastic and stuff like that
I'm sure I have an old gloves that I can
use and some pieces of metal and strap
alright we're just going to dive right
into it and see what happens
so here I am just basically rummaging
through all my excess parts I wasn't
exactly sure what I was going need or
use but I knew I just gonna have to come
out of my bag of tricks
here I'm just cutting some piece of
aluminum tube and plastic tubing to
basically create only hydraulic so that
when you camera move your arm could see
the piston and stuff like that moving in
and out
and for the glove that's actually just
two pieces of MDF board that I cut into
that shape to give it that kind of claw
kind of shape and duct-taped it to
either side of the globe and it's animal
plant that I took apart and that became
the thumb finger and that's just a scrap
piece of plastic that I heated up with a
heat gun and formed around my wrist
some of the other pieces that plastic
piece on unscrew the entry right now is
actually a scrap piece of from Iron Man
mask that was left over from my
star-lord mask build that I did it
really was kind of an organic process of
just adding some Springs and different
hinges and stuff like that and screws
just to kind of see what worked nothing
was really set in stone when I just kind
of wait around and see what kind of give
it the most movement or what looked the
best
the inside of the clamp pieces had to be
ground down and sort of sanded out
because it couldn't fit my fingers in
there with the glove I figured I wanted
to give it enough room
even though tailors hands are gonna be
much smaller that even with the glove on
I wanted to fit inside that that clamp
and see all the elements are starting to
come together all of the rods and the
tubing and stuff like that the bogus
hydraulics are we gonna have to cut down
I knew once I fitted it to Tamara but
that's why I left all those pieces long
that cylinder is actually from it was
like a hairdryer brush I bought it at
like a goodwill or something probably
months prior to that with the intention
of training into like a flame thrower
nozzle or something okay Raygun there I
don't know when I saw the hand and stuff
in a movie and everything I knew exactly
I was gonna use that piece for it just
cut it up and add it to the fingers
awesome okay and then yeah stuck in
there and then maybe another actually a
piece here and another piece here yes
that's what you guys are good for in my
life there was a long day every time I
put it on this as the second time doctor
I think that I'm messing up because the
fingers are together
forget that yes as work of art I'm just
talk about Jim the perhaps pretty cool
to see what you did this
you should hear us when we're bored
making props all day fortunately Jim's
taste in music doesn't suck most of the
cities have been good though that one
with the like 16 minute intro I was like
did we switch to the class
oh man so coool let's be a poster arm
and see how they feel if it feels too
restricting or if you can good good yeah
you can't design a slide and move it so
that you can now say enough kid gloves
mr. valiant now you know how I fell
yesterday when I was important Joe yeah
once all the once the outfit was undone
like wow I'm actually really miserable
but this is the greatest day of my life
cram session you know is like I really
get this time I'm gonna do this but at
the same time again let me make sure
it's not too tight no that's good it's
okay yeah all right showed off beyond
kid gloves mr. variant is yeah move the
fingers nice this is so cool Oh critic
someone wants to crush your neck well
done Jim MacGyver
most people don't realize I made this
entirely out of popsicle sticks
it's just spray-painted popsicle sticks
all right I'm almost like do this leave
it on just leave it on no just stay in
character all right guys thanks a lot
for watching next week is gonna be part
4 it's gonna be the final part in this
series we're gonna look at the model
cars and trucks that I built for the
review thanks again and see you next
time